il a connu les sommets une renommée
nationale et internationale de danseur
étoile
il a côtoyé les plus grands comme
maurice béjart et soudain un accident de
la route en 2000 qui a bien failli
mettre fin à cette carrière bien remplie
plus les capacités pour danser et
pourtant patrick dupont fait face du
travail encore du travail
une force d'esprit et une rencontre avec
leïla da rocha auront eu raison des
pronostics médicaux
c'est elle qui a décidé de me faire
remonter sur scène c'est elle qui m'a
remis dans le droit chemin
on va dire je pense que patrick ait
quelqu'un juste d'exceptionnels comme
disait rudolph noureev il a du génie et
les génies ont un rebond une faculté de
rebondir
hors du commun et j'ai juste été une
main tendue peut-être à un moment de sa
vie où il avait besoin de quelqu'un pour
l'emmener sur scène lui le danseur
classique elle la danseuse orientale
forme d'un duo désormais inséparables
ils ont fondé tous les deux une école de
danse à soissons ont monté un spectacle
et ont encore tous les deux écrit un
livre à paraître à la rentrée prochaine
on est tellement les mêmes on se
complète tellement voilà comment la
réponse à votre question il a commencé
une phrase là fini où je la commence
elle a fini quand l'un à une baisse de
régime c'est l'autre immédiatement prend
le relais et anti en ce sens on
s'entraîne à l'autre on se
on se nourrit l'un de l'autre et c'est
encore à deux qu'ils viennent distiller
leur savoir dans ce stage de danse à
nazelles négron
lui pour la danse classique elle pour la
danse contemporaine
et en face des filles qui n'aurait
jamais imaginé à prendre avec les plus
grands et là c'est impressionnant et
laisser intimider
on savait qu'un danseur étoile c'est un
rêve de petite fille exaltant on a envie
en fait de les écouter de les regarder
de d'apprendre tout ce qu'ils ont bien
voulu nous donner un stage qui a affiché
complet en trois jours mais ne parlez
surtout pas la professeur de danse d'une
belle opération communication annonce
est ouvert à tout le monde
déjà dans mon école c'est le le mot
voilà c'est qu'on soit grand petit gros
ou minces fin n'y a pas de ses passes et
à la danse c'est vraiment une partager
ensemble et donc non ça va au delà de la
communication une ouverture sur l'autre
et une philosophie du partage et de la
transmission du savoir qui auront poussé
le binôme da rocha dupont à choisir
nazelles négron on aime le principe que
la danse serve à quelque chose entre
guillemets c'est que ce soit pas du
mouvement pour le mouvement eu des
pointes des tutus pour les tutus des
arabesques des trucs comme ça pour des
trucs comme ça on s'en fout nous ce
qu'on veut c'est transmettre un message
qui est un message de paix d'université
la simplicité l'humilité
l'exigence l'effort leurs déplacements
sont rares ça valait bien la médaille
communale et hissaient le toutou de
leïla lui aussi aura bien aimé la
recevoir